[Music]
hey everyone i'm
lucy and joining me is john luke seipke
hello
and phil hornshaw hey to talk about
cyberpunk 2077
now phil has been playing the game has
played a lot of the game
uh so hopefully this video will kind of
act as the
final video preview we hope for
cyberpunk 2077
please don't delay it again i've
i've got my calendar like i've got
diamond marked in december for me to
just relax and finally play the game
uh so phil first of all how much
cyberpunk did you play
so i started at the beginning of the
game and ran through about
16 hours across two whole days
that's a lot of gaming and uh how were
you how are you actually playing it
um on pc we were doing a whole like
streaming remote
thing so it was like uh you know not
probably quite
the quality that people will expect when
they actually play but still look pretty
great
um even streaming over the internet damn
all right well we'll get
deep into performance and stuff in a
little bit but i want to know what is
the kind of
overview you know which life path did
you pick and how did you split that time
16 hours
is one hell of a chunk um were you just
mainlining the story or were you
dabbling inside missions too
um so i started with the street kid life
path which kind of
just drops you in the middle of the
gangs in night city and you're already
kind of working with everybody and you
know everyone
um sort of in the watson district you
have a little bit of a reputation
but you know you're trying to grow your
legend um
as a mercenary and yeah i i found the
main story actually pretty compelling i
was kept trying to break away for sight
stuff and i was just like
maybe i'll just keep going um but it's
kind of interesting the way
that cyberpunk plays out as you work
through the main story
there are points where that feel like
pretty natural branches like you get to
a point where
you've got two or three people that you
want to track down to kind of get
information about what's going on with
you
and the whole like johnny silverhand
biochip thing
so like you have multiple paths right
there still feel like main story
but take you off in different directions
work into different
investigations almost um so yeah i
mostly stuck with that kind of stuff um
if here and there
you also pick up other characters right
like you
work with other mercenaries you get to
do other jobs that are part of the main
path but kind of
also give you people that you now know
and are in your orbit
and then they have side missions so i
picked up a few of those finished off a
few well
i never really got all the way through
any of the character arcs i guess
they're pretty involved
but i did start off with a few people
who were pretty cool um
yeah so i got a little bit of a taste of
i think
most different sorts of things there are
also things that happen on the street
like in miles morales and spiderman
um and all kinds of other side things
that i never got around to
but i got a little bit of a look at
everything i think
so phil you mentioned you played the
game on uh pc even with streaming i'm
curious if you could talk more about the
game's performance i think that's
probably the big lingering question that
uh at least i have about
the game we you know cyberpunk uh they
recently showed off
some footage of it running on the uh
series x as well as the one x and it
actually looked pretty decent but um
how do you feel like the pc version uh
stacks up that's probably gonna be like
the premiere
experience i guess yeah so you know
looks pretty great it's a pretty great
looking game in general even
streaming over the internet um i also
got a chance to spend a little bit of
time
um with like the retracing tech um on an
rtx
3080 again streaming over the internet
so like not perfect but
really impressive um just looks great
night city looks amazing
all the neon and the reflections and the
rain and
uh it looks very much like blade runner
or johnny mnemonic or another movie
in the cyberpunk genre that you've seen
it looks awesome um
my preview uh did see like some
like weird issues that you the sort of
things that you kind of expect from a
giant open world game
people acting a little strange or like
popping in and out occasionally stuff
like that
there's a portion where i got on a
motorcycle and then for some reason my
arms were like
out this for you know a good chunk of
the
preview after that so it's like there
still seems to be
a little bit of polishing work they're
probably working on
but it looked great it ran pretty well
most of the time
um you know dealing with our tech issues
of
the pandemic but uh yeah i ran all over
the city i got outside of the city and
it was all very very cool so you're
playing
with a developer kind of guiding you
through at least
you know there to be able to bounce
questions off uh you also released a
preview
you wrote about what sex is like
in cyberpunk 2077 and i have to ask you
about this because reading your preview
was like first of all i applaud you for
asking the question
because everyone knows that's what
everyone is going to go and do in
cyberpunk they're going to try and have
sex
what was it like talking to a developer
about having sex in their video game and
then going going through the motions
going through with it
uh it was awkward it was very very
awkward um
you know they they
they knew that like we would be
interested in that sort of thing that's
what people you know
pr brought it up as i was running around
um but i put it off for
like a whole day i was like building
that rapport with the developer
yeah like i slept on it i was like i got
it
people are going to want to know i have
to do it like i felt like i wasn't doing
my job
if i did if i didn't try it out um it's
really
not that big of a deal it's if you've
seen um
sex scenes in the witcher 3 like you
have a sort of
sense of what it's going to be like it's
so maybe a little bit longer maybe a
little more
um involved in a little more graphic but
not terribly so
um but yeah i tracked down like a sex
worker in one of the
districts and gave her some money and
then like there's a shortcut scene and
that's
pretty much it so um but sex is a big
part of this game like
a lot of the story concerns like the cd
underbelly
of night city and um sex workers and
like human trafficking and all kinds of
stuff the kinds of things that you
expect with
the cyberpunk world and also the idea of
um cybernetics and
body harvesting and all kinds of stuff
like that so um
it's humorous in a lot of its inclusion
but it's also very dark
yeah i wonder if video games will ever
actually get to the point where sex is
not
just a thing that makes people kind of i
don't know
i don't think i've yet to see it be
tackled in
any taste it's kind of like it takes
peaceful ways it's a good kind of way in
any kind of
uh but you know god knows what the the
mainstream media will make of this one
because uh yeah
uh well i think one of the big things
that they talked about in
the last night city wire was johnny
silverhand obviously he's a big deal
because he's played by
keanu reeves but uh they talked about
how he's
basically like the second protagonist of
the game and plays a very major role
what was your experience actually
getting to like play the game and like
play with or as johnny right so we've
had a sense for a while now
in different previews and stuff of like
what kind of role johnny plays like he's
in your head
early on as part of the story you um
acquire this bio chip
that's a prototype it malfunctions after
you get it in your head and then you're
stuck with johnny he's like your
imaginary
tyler durden friend um what
the stakes of that are is that that chip
is broken in your head and it's built
to like they copied johnny onto that
chip with the
the purpose apparently of like plugging
him into another body and having
him be reborn in that body so when you
get it in your head
it's starting to take you over right so
like wow
johnny is not necessarily just um a fun
friend to have around to give color
commentary to
uh he is and through no fault of his own
because he's just a computer program
like potentially taking over your brain
so you have this sort of
uh um antagonistic relationship with him
from the start
and how you deal with him is sort of up
to you that
uh cd projekt has talked about how like
you will shape that relationship
but you also kind of have this like
weird feeling of
yeah if i'm friends with johnny and i
help him out does that
make my head go weird like is that going
to make it
worse for me or if i'm am i wanting to
do these things because
he's taking me over like that sort of
thing it's a cool
uh narrative construct he's around a lot
there's a lot of
keanu in this game which is super cool
um and yeah and there are scenes where
you get flashbacks of johnny's life
because
you know he's in your head but you're in
his too kind of and so there are times
when you get a chance to
sort of see flashbacks of johnny's life
before he was killed back in like
the 2020s um and you get to like
play as keanu a little bit that's really
cool i never actually
expected it to go that far with it i
mean i think
no one figured that keanu would play
such a huge role and
you know because you kind of hear when
celebrities are going to get added to
games they usually like
yeah you know he every so often you can
get to chat to them but having him be
this constant presence is something i'm
very excited about i'm a very big
keanu reeves fan i'm also very excited
to see like there are so many crossovers
i know because you're kind of dealing
with very similar themes but like
there are so many crossovers between
altered carbon and
you know like having people's
consciousness on a chip but also one of
the places you visited
is basically the pretty much the same
it's like the brothel called
clouds i believe right and so in altered
carbon you have a very similar thing
with a place called it's like in the sky
it's like clouds in the sky
so i'm very excited to see that yeah
it's
it's a really cool game like i feel like
it is super aware of the breadth
of this cyberpunk genre um and so you
get like a lot of instances where it
feels like you're kind of crossing over
into different stories and different
worlds and there are a lot of little
nods there's a
portion you play through in the main
story where you wind up at baddies hotel
which is a blade runner reference that
like is
very glaring and like it's great it's
cool
so it seems like you know cyberpunk is
its
own universe but it's also um it seems
like
cd projekt is very aware of everything
that's in the cyberpunk genre and they
want to appeal to everybody who is going
to be looking for those sort of easter
eggs
and i hope as well that it kind of feels
like and you can answer this is like
does it feel like a cohesive world
within itself and you know
you kind of mentioned that these
missions that you were doing had these
long and short-term consequences
does the whole thing manage to feel i
don't know it's been in development so
long you've got to hope that it has this
really
focused story and focused world and you
know your actions have these
consequences and they branch out
everywhere
yeah you know like like i said i got
pretty well
uh dragged along into the main story
like i had a hard time breaking away
um i really wanted to track down like
each new piece of the mystery
um you do cool things like jump into
these brain dance
virtual reality scans where it's
somebody like wore
or recorded their own experience and
then you get to like
watch that through their eyes and then
you can kind of break away from it also
and
learn things about what they saw that
they didn't even necessarily know that
they saw
um and you you do all these like aspects
of it
um but as you're as you're walking
through night city and following along
that story
you're also building up a lot of
reputation just
everywhere you go you know blasting
through gang high notes and doing jobs
for people and stuff
and it really felt like i was making a
big impact
on night city and i felt like i was kind
of carving that path
for myself everything you do you know
games that are heavy on choice like this
you know that you're making choices that
don't
necessarily like branch in every single
direction right like
every time you pick a dialogue choice
doesn't necessarily mean that the guy
who answers you is going to be saying
something different
but so many of these choices you're
making them so often and they
feel like they matter so often as how in
how you deal with
you know your fixers and your other
characters and anybody you encounter um
it really feels like you're kind of
guiding night city and you're
building your own like real reputation
as you're going through the story so
yeah it felt like really cohesive
just in that i felt like i was there i
felt like i was
important in night city and then night
city was responding to my
influence on it so it was cool
so when the game finally comes out
crossing all fingers and toes for
december 10th um
they i mean they reiterated the date a
bunch of times in night city wire so
i'm holding out hope that it is going to
be december 10th are you going to be
making the same decisions are there
things that you're going to be
specifically looking out for
on this second playthrough that you're
going to have or are you going to
you know just maybe do some uh similar
stuff than what you did this week
so i really want to check out the uh the
corpo life path
um i haven't really seen how that works
out but
you know you interact with the
corporations quite a bit but they always
seem
pretty evil right so
um and as as the street kid you like
you already are really untrusting of
those guys
and then every time you encounter them
they're kind of like trying to pull one
over on you it seems like
so i would really like to check out what
it's like to start in the high-rise
and like have that whole weirdo
background
um the other thing actually so i kind of
wanted to do it twice
do three runs um the other life path is
nomad and it starts you outside of the
city
and i had not encountered any of this um
in like i haven't been paying super
close attention to cyberpunk coverage
because i wanted to kind of like stay
unspoiled by it but so part of this
preview
i did missions that take you outside of
night city and like encountered some of
those nomad people and they have like an
entirely different experience
of the world so i it all seems really
cool i want to kind of go and
and see how it all shakes out
differently well hopefully you don't
have too long to wait december 10th is
right around the corner
phil where can people find your full
preview
oh on gamespot.com we've got two of them
so please enjoy it goes into much
greater detail than we've managed to get
into today uh john luke
phil thank you so much for joining me
and for everything to do with cyberpunk
2077
keep it game smart
[Music]